hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica ghosts
are still chasing us we get a lot of
stuff to do and not a lot of time to do
it so I'm going to get right into the
quickness and I'm going to dilute my way
over to the only other alien cache and I
have not found and I'm going to find it
very good today because I know exactly
where it is it is that negative five
five four negative five three four one
five two one
and the more intense you say the more
realistic it becomes and I'm currently
at Oh Oh negative eleven five three one
so i'm close and by close I mean I'm not
anywhere near close and I'm actually as
far away as I possibly can be but I'm
gonna go there because I need to get
more ion ion crystals because I don't
think there's a way to get them just yet
in the future I've been told that
there's a development build that is
going to have Oh buncha ion crystals
more of those things that I can just
mine
you know the dangerous ability of
shoving your diamond drill into a
nuclear bomb and then just hoping that
it's not going to blow you to [ __ ] that
sort of thing yeah i'ma do that but
along the way because I'm pretty sure
that it's pretty close to here I'm gonna
go as a life pod that's carrying
Mongolian emissary jokey pasar because I
don't know why but it made it seem like
they were talking about his funeral
before he was actually dead which
normally I can appreciate it but in this
specific endeavor I don't think that's
very good for him or me so I'm going to
find out what's happening in this zombie
life pod very soon and in the meantime
I've got more comments to read the first
one is by chuckle bones there's a tool
in subnautica called the transfuser that
you can use to take samples of DNA from
other creatures and either put them into
other creatures or inject them into
yourself perhaps this could be the means
of a cure which makes a lot of sense
considering they're going to have to see
emperor in the game which means that the
sea emperor is going to be the only
thing in the game that is immune to the
kirara virus which is infecting
absolutely everything in this world
that's important because the Kirara
virus is in me and every other living
thing it is somehow breached containment
I can only assume when the Aurora
crashed down into the planet it actually
skewed the entire containment system
just crashed in and destroyed everything
that was supposed to be there and oh my
god there's life pod 3 well I didn't
expect to be skating over you just like
that I hope I hit you on the way over I
got the Mongolian emissary joke ekeus
are waiting for me here you you freaking
old anonyme light pot 3 this is a guy
that's just desperately grabbing on to
big bucks Barry oh please I'm alive no
come on shut up dude get out of my face
I got the emissary of Mongolia joki cos
are waiting for me to bury his dead body
we're more important than your living
body get the [ __ ] off of me
just stupid life pod 3 so I'm going to
go over there and thank you chuckle
bones I will get these names on the
lockers very soon or the name plates
which I discovered that I do have very
soon and then Lindsey s the noises in
the sub or driving Marc insane Marc
insane Marc insane the noises in the
supper dropping Marc insane all through
the sea nothing really more to that
comment that song there which is
pleasant enough I mean resonates with me
in my heart here so that I think I feel
more at home when I'm in the dark depths
of my mind and see and then the next one
is Cameron Douglas who said build an
aquarium to plant couch and creepvine so
the aquarium as my voice cracks computer
T the aquarium is the inside the base
device that is just a large tank of
water and in that I can grow Koosh and
creepvine
which means that I'll have a steady
source of it and I also think you can do
it in the X series grow beds outside of
your base so I'm going to experiment
this with borer before I actually go
down in the deep because the deep having
a base down there is nothing more than
an ego trip literally the only reason I
want to do that is for my own ego and I
know it's bad but I'm gonna do it anyway
oh god I'm in the mushroom area I can't
see [ __ ] do I not have my lights on I
don't okay I'm gonna turn my lights on
real quick here
I can't see Garbo OOP there we go that's
better
a little better a little better anyway
so let's see if we can get a camera here
how do we get the camera I have I forgot
now to get the camera what oh that's
right it's a button yeah there it is
okay where are we now nah nah there we
go
oh pretty oh you so pretty oh my god I
wonder if there was anything ever
anything that I could actually do with
these mushrooms because it seemed weird
that there was just all these mushrooms
here and yet what could you have done
about it oh did I miss did I miss the
Mongolian emissary jokey guitar I think
I'm gonna miss the emissary jokey kazar
is he around here somewhere above oh
okay I hit some don't know what might
have been a mushroom
all right so he's around here somewhere
who do we got jokey Kassar Oh
emissary jokey kazars right below me I'm
gonna go against my better judgment I'm
gonna go without my girl
well jokey Kassar doesn't seem to be
here and there seems to be large things
that are missing from the terrain here
that's weird
so what the hell does this mean
what the [ __ ] well that's super weird
okay apparently Mongolian emissary jokey
Kassar is the ghost that has been
haunting me this entire time I've been
here and I'm gonna take this excuse me I
got a creature agate I don't know what
it's too but I got it okay so that's the
only thing that I wanted to do here so
I'm gonna just skip ahead and go to the
I'm gonna go to the the thing the alien
cache location so I'll be right back
when I get over but very soon there very
soon whew hey oh wait wait Wow well well
well
woah wow man
I'm from where'd you go where'd you come
from cotton-eye Joe there is a lot of
supplies here so I'm gonna make a pit
stop right here and I'm gonna go gather
as many supplies as I can I'm also going
to dump my inventory right now because I
don't need it
there you go Grom oh no groms got the
couch oh and also whispering potatoes
who has the coolest name I've ever heard
and yes the potatoes do whisper at me in
the night fat mark do you still have the
Katy poster because if you don't I'm
going to have to come over here and jog
with you about how far that Bazar is we
say you still have it please and of
course I have to keep calm Kitty poster
I would never leave home without the
Keep Calm Kitty poster what do you think
I am a barbarian
now I've always got to keep Tom's Kitty
poster on me at all times because I need
it anyway that's all I need about that
so I'm gonna gather and it's just about
day two so I'm gonna go get me some
supplies squiddy's clip clop splitting
steel or God yeah I'm at ah the still
suit I knew I needed fiber mesh for
something oh I can make that still suit
and then I can drink my own piss which
is the only reason I wanted to have that
in the first place and no one is going
to question me at all because it's a
good thing it's a good thing to drink
your own piss because it's a survival
tactic and no one here can judge me
especially you Karen because it's
important for survival everybody
understand me now I just got to find
where I put my fiber mash right there
now I'll make me a still suit because
radiation is no longer a concern so I
don't need it everybody understand it's
for survival it's a survival thing
hell yeah Karen yes I am and you
wouldn't judge me about that would you
I don't think you would anyway you
better not because that's that's bad you
shouldn't do that you shouldn't do that
the status of the aurora's crew and the
ship's long-distance communications
relays enter me in determinate if any of
the ships data cores remain intact it
may be possible to salvage this
information really is there a reason for
me to go back to the rora i mean i know
in the last one it said that there might
I say that there might be but that was
just a might maybe
based on what somebody said so maybe
maybe I will be going back to the aurora
very soon
[ __ ] sploded my spleen Rhys leave me
with a new subway clap right hey hey
this clue be alright we're all done
farming on we go to the point of the
singham ABAB herb of things we're gonna
you get Oh before I do that though
before I do that there's one more thing
that I want to do and a lot of people
have been telling me to do this for
quite a while because I don't know why
I've been so hesitant to do this but I'm
going to make myself all bad and I'm
only gonna make it for one person
because all my friends are dead little
bit you here by the driver Z because why
I didn't make it anywhere else there was
dead yeah arms right there's good for me
yeah okay that's good I don't need your
if there was so much I could use that
consoles I'd put them there but they'd I
don't have anybody I got nobody
ah there's a bad yeah right there so I
can sleep and all the fish can watch me
sleep and there's like people are
wanting to be around B except it's not
so yeah anyway I'm going to sleep my
nightmares away I'm just gonna lay down
my hand and rest my weary bones
all asleep again I can't sleep okay I
got reclaimed water oh good good alright
YUM let me drink that piss and sweat the
mixture of it what's a good thing to
wake up to I'm pretty sure that's a
balanced breakfast tell me the tiger
would be proud of me yeah
anyway gonna carry on to the cache now
because I'm not very sad and lonely
alright we are getting close I need to
dive dive dive so I think I think this
one is located in the blood
kelp zone that I actually left the Lost
River from there is another entrance to
the Lost River and it is near here right
in this area with these weird chains
floating rocks or maybe they're
suspended by the weird blood kelp that's
here because it's all unnatural here and
I do not like it maybe actually get some
samples of this but I don't think it's
going to be any use to me that must be
close yeah I'm right on top of it I need
to dive dive dive dive
oh hey crab squiddy Oh squid of you
squid an odd squiggly squid Oh Lou might
be over this Ridge now it's right below
me somewhere so there's got to be a way
down below hey warper buddy blue how
about i ram into you
would that be fun okay so I think I got
to go either down there or down there
I'm thinking down here is going to be a
better way for me to get in let me start
navigating using these sons of [ __ ]
wow that looks bad
that looks like a whole lot of bad but
it looks like a whole lot of where I'm
supposed to go slit you're gone oh yeah
oh that's scary hey buddy hey how you
doing okay somewhere around here and I
definitely haven't been to this one
before because this is uh this is
territory that I really haven't explored
this whole blood group areas just
completely foreign to me like of all the
areas that I've explored in subnautica
disguise to be least used to populated
of any of these well oh that's it that
is it right there okay
I'm gonna hop out I'm not even going to
take mr. Pfister oh it's weird being
closed off like this and also attached
on a ramp here but I'm gonna go into
there and I'm gonna brave this because
I'm a big brave boy but uh here we go
my Magic's not gonna be that bad because
it's got to be some air down here
somewhere maybe there's not nothing to
be risking my life oh no oh no it
requires a part of fact I don't have a
part of fact I need to go get one ooh do
I have enough Dimond uh yet yeah I'll be
right back I need to go get either
diamonds or everything I need to be able
to get through here yet chat ah I got a
diamond okay we're good we're good
everything's good we're good the siren
is calling for me out there which is
leading me into the rocks that I'm going
to crash into but enough about that
let's get our way into the son of a
[ __ ] cave and hopefully not die a
horrible death you
okay so I don't know what else is in
here besides more ion crystals but we're
about to find out but laughing this
thing in there man I wish I could use
that again I don't know why that's got
to be all temporary Gazoo okay all
righty then done with that noise over
I'll take you and the you and the OData
yes please alien sanctuary be you and
you will thank you thank you very much
okay so I got those you look like that
was the only thing in here I'll read the
data and I just remembered that I need
to read the data from that crashed ship
that I found in the last episode I
didn't quite get to that so I'm gonna do
that immediately now evident habitat
would give me in okay there we go so now
I'm gonna go up here and by my bed of
which I'm very lonely I'm gonna raise my
ship out of here and then I'm gonna read
yeah you know I work good here in the
view of the dark depths and no escape
anywhere is good enough for me okay I'm
gonna turn down the lights and get real
moody for storytime here
yeah it's getting creepy oh my god
that's creepy uh why do I have my bed in
here I don't know I'm desperate
alright here we go databank technical
now that wouldn't Bennett did downloads
we had public documents so the Charter
definitions trans gov de facto control
of at least one system huh citizen a
person who consents consciously or
implicitly could be Authority and
recognized trams gov the Charter train
system Federation trans system phase
gate pump each trans growth is to have
an equal right to the most extensive
basic Liberty compatible with the
similar Liberty for others
each trend covers the right to on phase
gates and planetary infrastructure each
trans gov it's an obligation to share
phase gate access with other trans
guards on equal terms
each trans got there's an obligation to
financially maintain and comply with the
tsf each trans gov has the right to
self-government subject to the
restriction laid out below no trans gov
may develop weapons and technologies
outlined in outlawed in appendix 91 no
trans gob shell engage in population
abuse that's not a lot of rules
so what this means is that in these in
this universe where humans have expanded
to the scars and they've they've
traveled the world in the universe in
the galaxy and they've inhabited many of
these locations it means that when you
have a control of at least one solar
system in phase gate you have a trans
government which means you have the
right to self authoritative Federation
which is very interesting because I
don't know how big that is
but anyway comparing the data on this
terminal with stored translations have
revealed new information about this
alien sanctuary the antechamber consists
of a series of main data hubs each
epidural with an ion crystal these are
networked up to the main terminal in
parallel presumably to ensure data
integrity over time unprecedented data
complexity stored data was scanned into
the system the local terminal original
data source was organic in nature
evidence suggests that this antechamber
served as a sanctuary of last resort the
aliens that built it in the event of
catastrophe they would retreat here and
somehow transfer themselves to data hubs
for preservation it is unclear whether
other members of the alien species ever
returned here or how many souls are
backed up on the hub's but the data
stored is far too complicated complex to
reconstitute with the little information
available so that is actually really
interesting because what that means is
that there are precursor aliens stored
in the computers of their technology
they aren't just like they aren't just
organic beings we've already covered
this they're at data so that means each
of those hubs powered by the ion
crystals which I just removed thank you
very much but also powered by the
thermal plant down below store basically
the lives of all the aliens in the hopes
that they can be downloaded into bodies
again but who knows when that could be
they tried to escape the virus so they
escaped the virus by leaving their
organic forms
and then they just waited I mean they're
waiting in cyberspace who knows if
they're even aware of it or if it's like
a soma situation where you don't know
unless you're powered up which is super
weird I mean be kind of like a prison if
you were aware in the computer and not
able to move
I'd be that'd be [ __ ] weird I don't
know yeah man I think I've already read
these yeah I did
I've already gotten these so that is
pretty messed up so anyway I think I
think II think yeah I'm all out of time
for this episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching in the next one I'm
going to make my way back to bubble butt
and hopefully reunite once again and
then continue my journey into building
the infrastructure that I need to carry
on and build that base down in the deep
depths and eventually kill that sea
dragon because I want to I want to have
a trophy and I'm gonna kill that son of
a [ __ ] I've already done a good amount
damage to them unless they're there are
two of them no I guess the one in the
lava zone is a different one than the
one above because there are two there
are definitely two if they ever get
freaky in the middle of the night I'm
not going to like to being around them
at them but we'll see that when we see
them so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]